Joe Biden has departed for Israel the US
is surging thousands of troops into the
region we're learning that several
thousand more are currently on their way
and they are preparing 2,000 more for
potential deployment currently it is
being reported by The Washington Post
that 19,000 Personnel are in the region
already with 2,000 more preparing to go
we are also learning that the US Embassy
and Israeli Embassy are being I don't
know the right word is for this besieged
I don't want to call it a protest it's
not a protest it's something else
they've tried to storm the Israeli
Embassy already in Jordan there's
reporting that in Beirut there is some
kind of attack on the US Embassy but
that may be incorrect we're getting a
lot of conflicting reports right now it
seems like what we can say more
definitively is that there was an
attempt to storm the Israeli Embassy in
Jordan the meeting between Joe Biden and
jordanan the Jordanian government has
been canceled and there is a tremendous
fear among many
uh commentators and political
personalities that Joe Biden is in
serious danger going into the region
right now and should not do it because
the risk and I'll say this is my opinion
the risk is not just to him it's to the
world if something happens to him but it
certainly looks like things are getting
very serious report has come out that a
hospital in Gaza has been hit by some
kind of Rocket fire the current I would
say in again my opinion uh likely
scenario is that Hamas fired a rocket it
misfired it hit the the hospital but
there's conflicting reports many on the
are saying that it was an Israeli strike
many on the right are saying Hamas
screwed up we'll break this all down but
it certainly looks like we are entering
a much larger war in the region
potentially the largest we've seen in
our lifetimes and with Joe Biden going
to the region things are about to get
extremely serious we could be looking at
a total of 21,000 US military personnel
in the region with already 19,000 there
we're going to talk about this before we
get started my friends head over to cast
brew.com and buy our coffee if you want
to support the show and you want the
best cup of coffee you've ever had head
over to casper.com and pick up some Mr
Bokus pumpkin spice experience you get a
picture of Mr Bokus the cat on every bag
you purchase and we've got Appalachian
Knights dark roast that's that's my
favorite to be completely honest rise
with robberto JR we sponsor ourselves to
be fair I totally get why a bunch of
advertisers would not want to run a
sponsor spot on a show where we're
talking about hospitals being blown up
and potentially very serious war and for
that reason we sponsor ourselves if
you'd like to purchase some awesome
coffee and support our cultural
Endeavors go to casper.com and pick up
your coffee today or head over to
timcast.net
timcast.net everywhere on social media
if you do like it really want to help us
out joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more we've got
Riley Moore hi thanks for having me back
on Welcome Back yes sir uh who are you
what are you doing uh I am currently the
state treasurer of West Virginia also
candidate for congress in the second
congressional district of West Virginia
so we have another story it's uh Biden's
going to request $100 billion do for
Ukraine and Israel and when we pulled
the story up Riley was like what like
and it's funny cuz you're a Treasurer
you're like how is that possible I was
like did you say million you're like no
billion and you're like no no no million
no billion you're like
how guess I just keep printing that
money that's right that's right we got
Shane Cashman hanging out what's up
proud to be here with my Treasurer my
favorite Treasurer yeah I'm writer for
timcast news recently at the GOP debate
where I saw Gavin Nome slip into his
skin suit and I have a story coming out
this week uh where I was with car he's
actually three demons stacked on top of
each other's shoulders I saw the suit
like that but uh and I have Story coming
out this week it's true they're going to
put out a fact check is some three
demons false I would love to see that
fact check crazy conspiracy theorist uh
yeah and I got another story coming out
this week with uh my time with Carrie
Lake uh when she announced her candidacy
for Senate awesome she's she's goingon
to be on soon um we're big fans of car
Lake she's awesome she been here several
times we got Libby here hey glad to be
back I'm Libby Emmons I'm the
editor-in-chief for the post millennial
and human events.com
uh yeah and I am still here surge.com
ready for the episode I don't even know
which which
story like they tried to storm the
Israeli Embassy I mean we're looking at
a massive escalation but at least I
suppose we'll start with where the
United States is currently at this
reporting just updated an hour ago from
The Washington Post Pentagon surging
thousands of troops toward Israel amid
Gaza War the US is projecting military
strength in the Middle East as its
diplomats race to prevent the crisis
from erupting into a broader conflict
I'm just going to say it seems like
they're not succeeding in that and
actually I think the US presidence May
make it worse here's the reporting
deployments disclosed by the Pentagon in
recent days will surge thousands of US
troops tour Israel I love how they keep
saying toward projecting expansive
military strength in the region as
American diplomats race to prevent the
war in Gaza from erupting into a broader
conflict the move include the moves
include the deployment of two US
aircraft carriers and their Associated
escort ships hauling some 15,000
Personnel combined the repositioning of
an amphibious task force made made up of
about 4 thousand Marines and sailors and
undisclosed increases to fighter
squadrons already arrayed throughout the
Middle East another 2,000 support troops
have been put on alert and told they
should be ready to go within days the
move follows hamas's stunning crossb
attack on October 7th this we all know
now I I feel like the reporting we got
on this one was put in the cart before
the horse and I think it was intentional
they're saying it's not an aircraft
carrier Striker it's two so an
additional deployment they keep saying
in the media they're being deployed
towards Israel y they're being sent to
the Mediterranean just outside of the
conflict and they're saying the Pentagon
is preparing them to actually go on the
ground I I I I was worried about this
last week when they reported you uh us
hostages were taken I said that's
usually the United States sending in
ground troops Special Forces or
something to go in and make those res
that rescue Gaza is not Iran so it's
more likely something like this could
happen but we the reporting we got the
other day was that 2,000 troops were
being prepped to be deployed just
outside Israeli Waters now the
Washington Post is telling us actually
19,000 Personnel already there right
with 2,000 more being prepped to go and
potentially into the
country yeah uh with the news that they
tried storming the Israeli Embassy this
all happening right now there's there's
a bunch of conflicting reports Hospital
been being bombed uh uh the meeting
between Biden and Jordan's being
cancelled now it's it seems like war is
is I think they're afraid they're afraid
to say War you know like everyone no one
wants to say I want to deescalate I
don't want war Netanyahu said war he
said war outright he declared war on
Saturday we also had hea which is the
Lebanese terrorist group they called for
a uh a an unprecedented day of anger
tomorrow um globally for jihadis
everywhere uh in response to Biden's
visit to Israel yeah they're saying
they're saying War they're saying War
well Hezbollah is saying war and you
also have Hezbollah and Hamas are are
backing each other even though one is
Shia and one is Sunni but they hate the
Jews in America more than they hate each
other mhm so the the the big concern is
uh uh right now we have this reporting
from ABC News Biden has departed for
Israel and canceled the the Jordan
Summit I believe I don't know exactly
why let's let's actually just uh just
pull this up and see what their the
latest development uh development is uh
they say Israel at least 400 people have
died 3,400 have been injured Israeli
forces launched air strikes this we know
conditions are are getting worse and I'm
wondering if uh there's the hospital
strike it doesn't seem uh he's departing
for Israel but it's not explaining do we
know why the the Jordan uh uh uh meeting
was canceled my concern is that there's
thousands these these videos thousands
of people I don't want to call them
protesters because it's it's it's it's
more serious than that they're not quite
rioting though but I wonder if this is
the reason why Joe Biden is saying we
can't we can't have this meeting or if
it's because the Jordanian government
was like that's it the the strike on
this hospital is too much for us we're
we're not having this we don't want the
liability of the US president here I I I
think it's the former and I one of the
things that's striking here to me is why
would you
announce that you're going to Israel as
the President of the United States
they're in war right now why would you
do that where we got two strike carrier
groups moving in we have escalation all
around the borders of Israel right now
with Jordan Lebanon and so on and so
forth and now you're going to announce
as the President of the United States
that you're going to go to Israel where
Hezbollah obviously has the capacity to
be able to reach Tel Aviv Jerusalem so
on so forth with any type of Hamas Hamas
and Hezbollah yeah Hamas and
Hezbollah you know it just seems like a
terrible situation C CNBC is saying that
Jordan canel the summit because of the
bomb of a hospital in Gaza now there's a
video of this and and and I don't want
to just rush too far ahead with all of
this stuff that's coming out now but
there is video that appears to show it
may be a rocket misfire although many on
the left are arguing that it was a
failed is Israeli interception in which
case there's a lot to talk about here
but before we get into all that let's
just say Joe Biden let's we we we'll
stick we'll keep it to the Joe Biden
subject right now I'm seeing people
tweet the concern that Joe Biden could
could is risking his life for no reason
these conversations can be had over the
phone from secure locations and going to
Tel Aviv right now going into Israel
it's stupid yes it it does it doesn't
make any sense but it shows it makes
sense if you want to cast his belly to
bring the us into a war in the Middle
East but it doesn't make sense for
diplomatic reasons well and let's say
you know God forbid and I me among any
many people would not want something
like that to happen some type of
escalatory conflict in the Middle East
but gosh wouldn't that look kind of uh
opportune to maybe invade Taiwan
if you're China well that is the next
thing I mean the next the next thing
we're waiting for is for China to go you
know lay Siege to Taiwan that's really
just the final and you just moved two
strike carrier groups over there so
that's basically fifth Fleet which is
stationed in Bahrain has now moved over
there and repositioned themselves off
the border of Israel third Fleet which
is out there in the Pacific on their own
wouldn't have any reinforcement because
fifth fleet's now tied up right what
would we do well we would have what then
we would have a war on three fronts yes
not to mention a POA Southern border
right yes with fears that Iranians have
already been captured Crossing through
as well as people on the terror watch
list so well and and they've reported
that that people on the terror watch
list have been captured at the southern
border like at least
151 those those are the people that they
know of it's impossible to know how many
yes going to the border is like it's
easier than TSA dud they tag your bags
they get you water and they give you a
spot to don't even check see gun in your
bag no there's so much news happening
right now it's like we've just told a a
history lesson in 10 minutes it's just
crazy I know and I with the Biden thing
I typically agree with you when you say
like having a normaly bias or positivity
bias but I think we're Beyond normaly
right now oh you know since Trump for
sure and and Biden going there it's like
to me he's a puppet and now I just see
the The Establishment using him as a
human shield to start whatever they want
to start so why would he go unannounced
to Ukraine do you remember he was
unannounced it was a year later and it
was a year after the conflict again and
so he goes unannounced to Ukraine but
he's announcing that he's going to
Israel why would you do that it's so you
could say maybe it's to make him appear
like a strong figure cuz he's hasn't
been at all but he's not everybody knows
that right so the argument the argument
people have brought up is that a wartime
president has never lost and I'm like
yeah that ain't Joe Biden though a
wartime president even George W bush
conveys some kind of strength and people
fear a dramatic change but if Jo is as
as frail and pathetic as he is people
are going to beg for change they're
going to be like we need a leader now
please the the joke's over we're sorry
we this guy just gets anybody else but I
mean look there if we've got 19,000
Personnel already in in in the waters
outside of Israel if if they are
reporting if they're reporting they
intend or or are preparing to go on the
ground then they're they're 10 steps
ahead of where we're what we're already
hearing about yeah I think that's
correct yeah when when they're telling
the troops to get ready for deployment
that that's what they're saying publicly
behind the scenes they've already moved
everything logistically the money's been
circulating the resources Food Supplies
everything's already on the move if
these troops are going to be ready they
need resources before they arrive which
means likely it's it's prepped and ready
to go yeah and I don't know you know
nobody knows I guess right now except
for the people and the policy makers
making the decisions what the thought
process is behind this is this to try to
secure some type of humanitarian
corridors through the southern border
there with Egypt is this you know cuz at
first they talked about the idea of SEAL
Team Six and Delta going in to help
secure uh us hostages which there are
Americans held hostage currently is what
they seem to think and there's already
what is it over 30 Americans that have
died over there in Israel um
so I I don't know um I don't know what
what you know I guess it's a projection
of strength and they doing it in a
manner to tried to deescalate the
situation but it could perhaps do the
opposite I think it I think with 19,000
Personnel in the area that's not
deescalation right you send in a single
Diplomat when you want to have a
conversation you call him on the phone
you want to deescalate and show you're
serious you send in a handful of us you
know uh diplomatic Personnel sending in
the war machine is a threat I suppose
the argument is Wag the Wag the big
stick and maybe they'll back down but
Hamas is not a group of people who think
oh no they have better weapons than us
staring down the barrel of Israel
Israeli air strikes for a very long time
they don't care they're ideologically
driven and willing to die for their for
their cause so sending the military
there is a provocation let's get a
little conspiratorial and the fear is
they're prepped for war warships ready
to go we I don't I don't think any of
these people want deescalation they're
War Hawks and War mongers they've been
advocating for us involvement Joe Biden
declares beforehand he's going then
every everyone in the United States
knows where he's going knows where he is
and he's leaving now and it's announced
and what happens as tensions are
escalating in the region rocket fire
today over and over again into Israel
reaching Tel Aviv Hezbollah strikes on
civilian on civilian civilian region uh
civilian territory or whatever you want
to call it and on
civilians if something happens to Joe
Biden and maybe they're maybe you can
think about it in a bunch of different
conspiratorial ways they want him to be
in danger they want risk they want
injury they want him Target
they want a cause for war it seems like
a sacrifice well every conflict that has
happened there that the United States
has supported Israel which just to be
clear I'm a huge supporter of Israel and
we should be helping the Israelis and we
should be helping the Jewish people but
we've never shown up with two strike
carrier groups MH to my knowledge that I
remember a lot of Carri I think this
puts them I think this puts Israel at
risk it's one thing when you have the
ongoing conflict between Israel Gaza
Palestine Etc we've seen it going on and
on with the uh with the Gaza war in
2014 it was the Israeli operation
protective Edge we had a great concern I
remember being in The Newsroom that this
could escalate to the point where Iran
declares some kind of involvement or
provide supplies forcing the US to to
respond in kind but that did not happen
it was 51 days things chilled out for
what reason now are they like let's
deploy two two two aircraft carriers and
the president into the region MH yes
we've seen an awful lot too on the other
side like we've seen Putin meeting with
Iran we've seen that Iran has been
meeting with Hamas and Hezbollah like
that's all been documented by The Wall
Street Journal we've seen all of these
reports coming out so I think it's fair
to say that Hamas is ready for something
large scale and long term they've been
planning this attack for a good couple
of years at this point they've been
planning it basically since Biden got
into office we've seen that the
documentation has come out you know um
and there's no doubt that when Hamas
struck Israel last week there's no doubt
that they were not aware of what the
retaliation would be they knew it would
be fierce they knew that they were going
into war that they were creating war and
they knew that um Israel would have a
disproportionately you know violent
attack that would be incredibly
horrifying for the civilians of Gaza
Hamas knew that of course they knew that
so everything that they are doing either
it's part of their intentional plan or
they're fine with it and they are using
like the the tragedy of their civilians
to generate sympathy exactly and I think
to your point what they want to do is
draw the Israelis in I mean there's
nothing more difficult than Urban
Warfare right right there's nothing more
difficult than that and you will lose
lives and there will be civilian
casualties there's things that are going
to happen in urban Warfare that
could um theoretically and we've seen
all the fake news that's out there about
what's happening uh in this conflict
that's trying to paint the Israelis in a
bad light that could be used uh to
Garner more sympathy uh around the world
for the Palestinian cause uh so yeah I
mean I think you're exactly right
they're more than willing to use their
own population as fod and human Shields
and everything else to be able to
further their cause let's talk about how
this uh is going to affect you here at
home before we go back to the uh War
Stories from The Wall Street Journal
Biden planning to ask Congress for $100
billion funding package for Israel and
Ukraine $100
billion get your contracts out where's
that money coming from so we've already
spent 113 billion on Ukraine alone since
February 2022 we've given Israel I think
38 million starting with a deal in 2016
that was like 38 million billion rather
overc just over three and half billion
dollars so we had there was a new in
between the United States government and
Israel uh for military financing the FMF
OU that we do with Israel that we've
done now for decades and that's part of
our funding for them to be able to uh
ensure their uh qualitative military
Edge I'm I'm cool with that money
honestly yeah and and I and I'm totally
support that I don't know how this money
breaks down the 100 billion like who
goes3 my problem is I'm I'm into like we
need to fix this country right now I I'm
supportive of Israel striking back I'm I
pray for the innocent people on both
sides but I've been like reporting
around this country so much this past
year and we are a mess everything's
collapsed I was in East Palestine like a
month after the explosion they they're
still in need right Lea burned down
they're shutting down I mean look CVS's
are shutting down targets Walgreens all
shutting down
was that was an opioid thing right but
but yes that is also very very bad uh
Bank branches are shutting down across
the board us infrastructure is
collapsing there's this viral video
right now of this woman talking she's a
Canadian by the way but you know we're
close enough neighbors she's talking
about how she wanted to get a salad and
some ribs and it was it was $45 and she
was shocked now I think one of the
problems here is that she blames the
grocery store for the high price which
is like that's like a Trudeau issue but
now that's Canada there m i want
everyone understand there's another
viral video that uh um I I uh I think I
recorded this for Friday so I don't
think it's up on my channel yet but it's
a guy comparing uh uh prices from Costco
a year on and it's like the cost of rice
has doubled the cost of mayonnaise has
doubled the cost of beans has doubled
and he's like yo they're saying
inflation is only a couple percent all
of the food Staples chicken the prices
are up
700% you spent another hundred billion
dollars we don't have that money well
and it's not just printing off more
money which we've been consistently
doing through the inflation reduction
act and all the other trillions of
dollars that we've been spending um
because of Joe Biden and the Democrats
and what they've been doing in Congress
secondarily to that is you have to
remember part of this is what does how
does food travel how does it get to you
it gets to you by truck it gets to you
by what are those powered by fossil
fuels fossil fuels right and what are
the Democrats trying to stop the
production of things like oil gas coal
things of that nature so they've created
essentially artificial scarcity in the
marketplace around things like oil which
then creates look the demand is there
supply and demand the supply is High um
or pardon me the demand is high and the
supply is low because of the artificial
scarcity and the regulations they put
into place around the fossil fuel
industry so to be able to transport
those items it's a pass through cost
it's going to go down to the consumer
it's going to always hit the consumer
it's a hidden tax you all are paying
right now for this war on the fossil
fuel industry literally at the grocery
store it's all part of the inflation
that's happening it's not just all the
money that they're printing but it's
also what they're doing in the energy
industry which literally transports
everything that you buy when I was in oh
sorry when I was in California it was $7
for a gallon of unlet gas and it all
started when Biden shut down the
Keystone Pipeline yes you can you can
actually look at the moment when Biden
is inaugurated not even the election and
you can see like an inversion in wages
and inflation and people are like oh
it's not Joe Biden's fault it's Trump's
fault because they his policy is rolling
into effect it's like no no no no you
can actually I think it was like Wall
Street Journal showed this graph and
it's like it just flips as soon as he
starts signing these executive orders
and people are asking how did shutting
down Keystone cause gas prices and
prices to Skyrocket when Keystone wasn't
even transporting oil these are people
I'm sorry they're first order thinkers
and this is what happens when you get a
woman who's like I blame the grocery
store for the high prices right these
people don't realize here's what happens
Keystone is being built to transport oil
from Canada into uh through the US and
then it goes south down uh to the gulf
or whatever for transport distribution
this means that when you're looking at
the market futures you're like okay do
we have enough supply for demand well
Keystone's been shut down which means we
are now going to fall short of Supply
with demand increasing prices are going
to go up then what happens people are
buying saying we better buy now which
causes prices to drive straight up now
your gas costs more money because Joe
Biden is negatively impacting the entire
uh industry and infrastructure and then
we tapped the Strategic petroleum
Reserve drained it drained that so
stupid yeah we drained that one it's
like I I I I remember watching that
happen and I was just like stop doing
stop doing that and and and and I just
want to point this all out and loop it
all back into a nice little bow all of
the things Joe Biden did have put us on
the path for total Annihilation if it
comes to uh International Warfare yes
we're not we're not ready we you know
the Strategic petroleums are spent down
right completely spent down and Trump
had filled it up and Trump had filled it
up and then the policies that you've had
these globalists pushing for years as it
relates to jobs in the United States and
de-industrialization like in the United
States right now we can make just over
16,000 artillery shells a month that's
what we can do the ukrainians are
spending 60,000 a month so we're trans
transferring literally out of stockpile
over to them which is affecting our
Readiness down the road the Pentagon has
a plan to increase this to like
24,000 uh 24,000 artillery shells a
month in the next three years does that
sound like we're ready for anything like
of course we're not ready not exactly
yeah we we rushed I mean just into this
service tech economy type thing that
we're living in now offshore all of our
manufacturing jobs if we have had a
World War II situation pop up here again
is there any way we'd be ready to um
industrialize the economy to be able to
build the uh type of Machinery equipment
and military equipment that we would
need to defend ourselves of course not
the only thing we'd have is like
Facebook and we could post a comment
being like the Chinese are invading this
sucks you the only thing we just meme
about it yeah yep it's terrible it'll go
down in the history of books as we all
winged ourselves to death right I'm
really upset about our new Chinese
Communist overlords they're making me
eat you know bricks and bugs and bugs
well there's definitely the bugs but it
does make me think of like the King
Dynasty right which was the wasn't that
like the isolationist dynasty in China
and they were isolationists for a long
time and then they emerged at the end of
that and they were like oh now we're
ready to rejoin the world and they had
gotten their a lot of their thing
together in terms of like who they were
as a people and Americans we don't know
who we are as a people you know I was
watching this video on Twitter today
this woman was like I was overseas and
these are all the things I hate about
America now and I was just like I hate
everything about you like I love
everything about America you know like
but you know and and we were like that
look we were protectionist rolling into
World War I it's you know we built
literally the greatest economy the world
has ever known and then after World War
II I think we had a pretty clear idea of
who we were right so what happened
Marxist took over the University
neoliberalism I mean just destroying the
United States rolling through the' 60s
7s and so forth and
now as we were just talking about this
um Israeli Palestinian
conflict it's been very interesting
because it's literally like in a
conflict you know think about World War
I where they send up a flare and you can
see where everybody is right now we're
seeing where everybody is like the
universities The Faculty everybody and
it's worse than I think than most people
thought it was well the universities are
about to lose a ton of money more and
more professors are refusing to back
down and so these big donors are like
we're not giving you money anymore y
good yeah they let them collapse I was
in those colleges teaching for too long
I saw I saw like Marxist teaching the
kids you know why I was in those
colleges studying for too long and in
New York right where as as worse as it
could possibly be but yeah I I really do
think the the universities are the big
problem of where our identity started to
erode I don't think it's universities I
think it's social media I think I think
social media accelerated it but I think
a lot of really bad people who were
actual like Marxist like people in The
Weather Underground who were terrorists
domestic terrorists then got out of jail
pardoned by people like Clinton you know
went into Professor became professors
and then taught you know Marxism I've
had this debate 50 billion times and
there are a lot of ideologies in
universities and just because one we
know of now doesn't mean that it's the
cause of it it just means it existed in
universities right and this is why we
thought that as soon as his kids got out
of college they'd have a cold wakeup
call but here's so let's let's put it
this way let's say there's the greater
world and there's University World
University world is woke these kids
graduate from college from woke
professors they should be thrown into a
capitalist world that chews them up and
spits them out no something else
happened those kids commanded power cuz
there were a lot of them no because of
social media because the kids would go
on and send 50 50 emails they would then
start spamming and McDonald's would
panic and these corporations would panic
and be like what's happening why are we
being act for this if there was no
social media apparatus these kids would
never get on TV to complain about
anything they would never come out and
say we think this company is racist
because they did X or Y the people who
run the company would be like they they
they'd go to the big media corporations
and say don't have those people on on
your show and they'd be marginalized but
social media gave them a free platform
and it uh the algorithms incentivized
intersectionality in far-left politics
because more keywords means more clicks
they made more money from it now when
you've got big corporations going to
these br Brands they're going to say
look we use Google AdSense our our
principal customers are a whole bunch of
small restaurants we don't care we're
going to run the article calling you
racist because it's going to make us a
million dollars and the way I see it is
that social media is an extension of the
Marxism they learned in schools where
they were taught like the culture
Revolution was good you know at least
what I'm hearing and then they see the
social media as a struggle session where
they can so the issue is all the other
ideologies that exist did not get that
boost and they're in colleges as well
and it's because social media algorithms
they take what is socially
plus whatever generates the most key
wordss possible which of course is going
to be racism social justice Etc so if
they if they started making videos that
were pro-white nationalism those would
be deemed socially unacceptable by big
Brands and otherwise it doesn't doesn't
happen Facebook doesn't want to be
associated with it so they create
algorithms that promote far-left
politics which is why Twitter went from
the Free Speech wing of the Free Speech
party into you can't misgender people
it's against the rules social media was
promoting these things Jack dorsy was a
free speech absolutist until he started
getting attacked by by by uh activists
but I I I I'll simplify because I do
want to move on to the next story none
of this could would would exist or break
through into the mainstream were it not
for social media platforms allowing or
or incentivizing companies to do it
example mike.com started off as Pro Ron
Paul and then turned into far-left
wokeness it's not because the
universities made it happen it's because
the social media algorithms created a
monetary course for any new blog and it
was PL painly obvious that Ron Paul was
not making you money wokeness was but
let's let's jump to this next story
because we got big war news uh shout out
to Raymond g Stanley Jr super chatting
this this is from defensenews.com house
drafts Bill to strike Iran proxies amid
Israel Hamas War ladies and gentlemen we
are on the precipice right now House
Republicans are running a military
authorization that would allow President
Joe Biden to strike iran-backed proxy
forces throughout the Middle East if the
Israel Hamas War escalates into to a
broader regional conflict Ford Affairs
chairman Mike McCall of Texas told
defense news on Tuesday he's drafting
the bill in case lebanon's iran-backed
militant group Hezbollah steps up its
attacks on Israel the prospect of
escalation comes as Israel continues its
week-long aerial bombardment etc etc I
hope you guys are ready man because a
grain of sand the saying I often use how
many grains of sand make a heap where's
the offramp as to quote Phil lanti if if
if we're at the point where troops are
being Reed for deployment 19,000
Personnel already there two two carriers
Biden is in route the peace talks that
the humanitarian Aid Summit in Jordan is
canceled you've got some kind of Riot
erupting in in in Jordan trying to storm
the Israeli Embassy and now the house is
saying we better draft a military
authorization to strike Iran yeah so ju
just kind of for background with me a
little bit I had worked on the hill on
the house Foreign Affairs committee and
so this this is an aumf right this is
authorization use of military
force these have generally been
completely open-ended we literally
fought a global war on terror for over
two decades over with the last
aumf so where does this end what's
What's the de you know and I don't see
the uh the legislation in front of me I
don't know what the language says this
is a slippery slope this can be a very
slippery slope we fought and died and
you know tried to eradicate obviously
terrorism all over the globe and it was
it was very open-ended uh obviously we
were attacked we had
um a very obviously emotional response
over that uh rightfully so uh but that
aumf continued on for very long time
very long time and if I remember
correctly still on the books now mhm a
shout out to another Super chatter cold
leftovers who made a good
point Joe Biden's heading to Israel
right now he's flying into into Israel
Rockets are currently flying through the
air the Super Chat
mentioned nothing bad needs to happen to
Joe Biden a rocket just targets or
explodes or in some way good point
causes some kind of interaction with Air
Force One that's it Air Force One forced
diversion after Hamas rocket nearly
struck
US president C it's almost like they're
provoking that just sending him there
right if if a rocket in any way
threatens the the presidential dispatch
or whatever that's that's that's that's
all they'll need to say look they they
tried to kill our president yeah that's
a big deal remember George Bush did that
he was like they tried to kill my dad
remember that that's right yeah well I
mean and but that wasn't a c's belly
that was him winging that was winging
for sure but if we can winge like that
then what does this look like like and
kind of the and we saw this even way
back in the day mujahadin uh in
Afghanistan the the asymmetric
technology that exists for terrorists
which we provided obviously to be able
to defeat the Soviets in Afghanistan
stinger missile these are heat seeking
missiles which literally rocket fired
it's a man PAD as they call it anybody
really I mean it's got a Seeker um it's
pretty easy to use they're all over the
place the Russians formerly Soviets also
manufactured them uh the sa versions
they're all over the place right now
look obviously there's countermeasures
in Air Force One and all these other
things it does make me think are they
moving like these strike carrier groups
there also because he's going there
interesting is is that part of the
reason you I don't know planning to go
there you know cuz they moved these they
moved the uh aircraft carriers a like a
good few days ago at this point wasn't
it over the weekend Saturday yeah and
they do have a ballistic missile defense
system on these destroyers right so you
got the B MD uh ballistic missile
defense destroyers attached to uh strike
carrier groups which are part of that uh
larger group of ships that go is that
you know I don't know it's just an open
question is that part of the reason
they're there so Joe Biden can go to
Israel yeah I don't know I don't know it
does make sense but it also also there
doesn't seem to be any reason like Tim
was saying there doesn't seem to be any
reason that he has to go to Israel you
know phone there's like just no reason
for that I mean how many times could you
schedule a meeting with someone to have
in person and then you just call them
via you know pick your video
conferencing or how about he meets with
all of these world leaders in Egypt in
Cairo right yeah somewhere more secure
or right there I mean the carrier group
the carrier group is right there next to
Israel Egypt Etc they could easily land
in Cairo and have the meeting there or
Bahrain literally oh yeah that's that's
where fifth Fleet is stationed is in
Bahrain I have been there they're there
centcom is in the region as well like
why not meet there um just you know I
mean but this guy you know he's got this
Napoleon complex as it relates to his
power and strength and everything else
that I think that's kind of part of it
and you know I think in the back of his
head Donald Trump's always kind of
eatting in him a little bit because
Trump himself s projects strength he
does Biden falling down set of stairs
about every two months certainly doesn't
right and maybe that's part of the thing
I'm going to roll two strike carrier
groups in here I'm going to fly in here
comes President Biden you know but is he
even making the decisions I was say I
don't know yeah Riley's being very kind
by saying Biden has his own thoughts
going on you know but I was also
thinking today about when Trump went and
met with uh Kim Jong-un you know that
was like a great he walked across the
DMZ way different situation there was I
right was a war it it it is a war right
but there's like he went periodic
Armistice or whatever you call it Donald
Trump meeting and walking you know uh
what did he walk like 100 feet or
something is an effort towards peace at
a time when bombs aren't being dropped
by multiple countries and you know it
was it was it's just not the same kind
of a smart move on his well in this it's
Donald Trump was meeting specifically
with the Enemy leader to negotiate peace
this is Joe Biden meeting with one
faction's leader at a time when Rockets
are being fired back and forth right and
there's tens of thousands of them aimed
at Israel to their North with Hezbollah
and you know I mean for
me it's it's hard to believe just a few
years ago I mean Donald Trump was the
Peace president there was no Wars we're
not dealing with any of this stuff when
he was president and I mean that's for a
reason I mean people see us right now I
think around the world and they see an
opportunity they see an opportunity to
do this stuff when he was speaking in
Iowa Trump was it yesterday he was
speaking in Iowa to yeah he said um my
personality kept us out of War that's
right and he's definitely not wrong
about that yeah he's definitely I'm
curious to see what would happen to
these Republicans who vote in favor of
another aumf I mean look they know they
can't beat Trump there's a reporting in
the Wall Street Journal today donations
to the GOP Rivals have stopped none of
these big donors want to give money to
losers anymore they're like these guys
can't win Trump's lead is GR he's
improving in the polls we're flushing
money down the toilet
yep people who are voting for Trump do
not want foreign intervention they do
not want more war they do not want World
War III I'm wondering what's going to
happen to the GOP uh members look
they're going to get a decent amount of
support I'm not saying everyone's
absolutely opposed intervention but 30%
I mean this this could this could cause
some of these guys their re-election G
was a joke going to that debate I mean
no one had a presence at all the only
Trump's lack of presence was more of a
presence than anyone on that stage and
then when Nome showed up he was the star
Hannity practically made out with him on
stage I was like this is ridiculous it
was crazy and then when I got there
people were telling me there there's
protesters on the street on the way up
to the Reagan Library I'm thinking
antifa like thugs it was Trump
supporters lining the streets of LA wow
because they're like we love Trump and
it was crazy you know the GOP is
completely weak yeah that is the the
weirdest move by Dan santis by the way
was you know to debate uh I mean it's
like he took the bait uh with um Gavin
Newsome over there and you know I I
think Gavin Newsome's arguably one of
the worst governors in the country he's
destroyed he destroyed California but
the guy's pretty slick and I that's not
a good matchup for Des santis no just
santis is horrible on stage he was a
great Governor terrible candidate yep it
makes you worry too because it's clear
that his campaign staff is not getting
the job done and you know those are the
same people that would end up in the
White House and you're kind of like if
if they can't run this campaign they
definitely can't run this country right
talk about Trump surrounding himself
with bad people first term these people
are terrible right and Trump had at
least discernment for sure this is crazy
what's going on man oh yeah well and
this and this is all premeditated on uh
D sanz's part not saying Trump wasn't
thinking about who he's going to put in
the White House in 2016 but it was kind
of like is this going to happen I think
it is I'm praying it is and it happened
but then you got the entire
establishment basically sending letters
like we refus to work in the Trump
Administration blah blah I mean so it
was few and far in between right now I'm
I'm hoping people are looking back at
this and like wow what a peaceful and
prosperous time in this country it
really was despite all the nonsense that
was going on Russia hoax collusion blah
blah blah all this other
stuff I mean it really was a prosperous
and peaceful time for this country I
often think over these last few years of
Trump's State of the Union that he gave
right before Co happened and it was so
happy and joyous you know tired of
winning type you know language and as
someone who taught narrative studies
fiction classes for 10 years I was like
oh no we're too happy right something
bad something bad it always happens in
the movie if they start out happy or if
it gets who a happy part if it's not the
end which I hope it's not the end it's
going to go bad and he dealt with
threats mhm in the way they should be
dealt with now remember Isis Obama Isis
is going to be a generational threat for
the United States JV team JV team you
know they had restrained Rules of
Engagement Trump snuffed them out in
like less than a year right right and
then what does he do he strikes solomani
over in uh Iran and is like don't mess
with us and he sent a message out there
you remember when he dropped a massive
ordinance penetrator on over there in
Afghanistan like yeah we're not playing
around anymore I want to pull up this
story from Times of Israel Hezbollah
calls for day of rage over Gaza Hospital
blast so the story there with the
hospital blast is a is disputed right
now all the leftists are basically
saying Israel uh uh uh destroyed with a
with an air strike a hospital killing
500 civilians however it is being
disputed many on the right or more
pro-israel are saying because it's not
just the right or the left but pro
Israel is saying this appears to be a
rocket misfire from from Hamas and based
on the footage I I can't tell you I'm
not an military ordinance expert or
whatever rocket expert it does look like
first you do see a rocket emerge from
Gaza and then in the middle of the air
it sputters out in a strange way and
then all of a sudden directly below it
you see an explosion it looks like it
may have been a misfire the rocket then
falls from the sky and slams blowing up
on the hospital but I don't know I don't
know for sure it's possible that um an
Iron Dome interception uh hit it and was
deflected and was invisible I mean I'm
I'm not being cute I'm saying had no
Trail no rocket you so it was at night
and for some reason you couldn't see the
Iron Dome rocket it's possible but my
understanding is that Iron Dome
interception uh uh which are Rockets
themselves you can see both there's that
famous photo of the Rockets coming out
of Gaza and then the uh the Israeli Iron
Dome flying up and intercepting them all
so when you see this video and a rocket
goes up sputters and then Falls straight
down it looks like a Hamas misfire yeah
and I think yeah and you're right it's
it is a little difficult to discern so
we actually we actually have a video
here it's it's super hard to see you
can't really see much you follow it
right
here and then it just bursts in midair
and then directly below
it I don't know if you can actually see
anything you see the you see the bang oh
directly
below
I'll I I'll say this
though the two stories it was well the
leftist argument was an Israeli air
strike but that video shows something
now many people are arguing the time
stamp doesn't make sense or whatever
okay fine I don't know whatever I don't
think I I think it would make more sense
there there is a post by someone who's
not an official with the Israeli
government saying that they hit a
hospital a terror a terror group using a
hospital as AB base deleted the Tweet
Israel saying No this appears to be a
Hamas misfire I think that's The Simple
Solution here I'm not trying to give
Israel a free pass Hamas is firing a ton
of rockets that are makeshift made out
of water pipes like the the misfiring is
extremely likely and probable if they're
firing thousands of them yeah look I'm
not uh an ordinance expert but if that
video uh is correct you see it in
ascendency and then you see something
yeah a burst and then something come
down so air strike certainly it was not
right I mean well but but assuming that
video is of the in question some people
are arguing the time stamp is off we
just don't know this is modern fog of
War where we're we're dealing with
propaganda where you've got the left in
United States just I mean a really great
example of this fracture would be uh and
I haven't watched it but Hassan
and Ethan Klein have a podcast together
and Ethan is married to a a woman from
Israel I believe she's from Israel and
she was in the IDF and Hassan is an
American leftist I'm not sure if he was
born in the US or or you know because
he's Jen huger's nephew and Jen was born
in in Turkey in asemble but uh the
fracturing there where Hassan is like
Israel is bad you know and then Ethan is
trying to be like but can we at least
acknowledge what Hamas is doing is wrong
it's like the left is fractured on this
one completely in the United States The
Divide is so Stark that if I mean look
the the us is going to be paralyzed if
it tries to fund intervention on behalf
of Israel because you've got a large
faction of the Trump supporting base
which are going to be like not a chance
and the entirety of the woke left not a
chance so so you're going to have
perhaps a plurality but maybe even a
minority in this country who would agree
with some kind of us involvement in the
region and that's that's going to lock
us out they're going to have to just go
ahead and do it but that's risking
destabilization in this country yep
that's why I urge everyone when I see
these videos to remain suspicious of of
anything that confirms any bias you
might have for this conflict because
people are reporting on this stuff
immediately or tweeting about it
immediately and they're like they seem
like they know exactly what it was I'm
like we've been through Co you know
we've been through a lot of things a lot
of lies in our generation it's like I
can't trust anything and you no we don't
see we don't see videos coming out of
Ukraine like this ever I just want to
say right now the truth matters to us
morally yeah but in this war it matters
none Hezbollah is calling for a day of
Rage he said the hospital strike was a
massacre and a brutal crime and even
though Israel is saying that it was a
Hamas M misfire all the Arabic nations
are saying nope you did this it doesn't
matter what really happened it matters
the Israelis aren't calling for like a
day of
Rage I know that but after they go into
a kabot and kill men women and children
the Israelis weren't saying let's have a
day of Rage all over the world and the
point is but that's they the fact of the
matters in this Hospital strike are
immaterial to what comes next the left
will accuse Israel they will rage
because of it whether it was true or not
well what's interesting too though is
remember last week we had the thing
where uh um whoever it was Hamas was
called the Hamas guy the ex the former
Hamas guy who was in Cutter yeah he
called for the day of jihad on Friday
and you notice how there wasn't a day of
jihad on Friday that's because these
things take time to plan like you have
to organiz something like this they
organized this massive attack for years
they organized you know 911 they
organized when they commit these Mass
atrocities so you know I think one thing
to worry about is like have they are
there more things things that are
organized you know like we're not going
to see a day of Rage necessarily unless
what we're seeing in Jordan and Beirut
right now when when you get when you get
a call for a day of jihad on the Fly
they say hey this Friday you get two
days to plan and nothing happens I'm not
surprised but now that those people have
been activated by the news last week are
now seeing this now they're going to be
mobilized more more likely so there's
embassies burning right now you know
right it's I think happen and people are
saying that there were pockets of
violence on Friday but the media has
refused there was protest and rs the guy
in California who drove through the
crowd uh that they were saying well
there was the guy in Brussels who killed
people the guy in Brussels guy in
Brussels uh the teacher Paris I mean
Hezbollah also they weren't just saying
that it was the hospital that's their
reason for the the day of Rage they said
that it was a an unprecedented day of
anger against the enemy and its crimes
against Biden's visit to the Zionist
entity to cover and protect this
criminal entity the message should be
clear that this is a day without turning
back on the path of resistance Victory
and retribution for the oppressed
against the oppressor so what they're
also saying is it doesn't matter what
you ever do we are going to fight until
we annihilate you yes well and look this
is an adage we've all heard but it is
absolutely true if the Arabs decided to
disarm tomorrow you would have peace if
the Israelis did you would not have a
Jew left in Israel right and perhaps the
world like yes I I mean it's and the
Palestinians have never missed an
opportunity to miss an opportunity right
every single time there's tried to
negotiate some type of two-state
solution they have missed an opportunity
every single time something real has
been put on the table which makes you
think they don't want peace right and if
this was some kind of pan Arab movement
then why don't the egyp Egyptians and
the jordanians and everybody else open
up their borders support them try to do
something they don't want them well they
value their own culture they don't want
that I want to pull up this tweet I just
saw Andy no retweeted it Gio confirmed
uh appears to be stating that it this
does seem based on geolocation data to
have been a Hamas rocket which uh for
some reason misfired fell down onto the
hospital you can see two explosions and
uh they actually go through the Geo data
they look at this this this is really
amazing investigation pulling up uh uh
daytime photos and then comparing it
with the with the news footage so you
can find the locations multiple videos
of the rocket here here's a better a
better video in the last one you can see
kind of what happens to the rocket going
up and then for some reason in midair
there's perhaps a misfire reasons
unknown and then of course you can see
the de two detonations on the ground so
uh look we don't know for sure but take
a look this is really amazing they've
got land markers showing what they
appear to be the same thing they believe
the geolocation data the coordinates are
all there the buildings they've
identified and they show the map and I
believe it looks like their conclusion
is uh a missile launched by a
Palestinian group exploded midair for
reasons unknown and one piece fell onto
the hospital causing explosion the
geolocation and timing of the footage is
conclusive more information will be
added to the thread this is from three
hours ago so a really interesting thread
uh they're saying it's conclusive I'm
still saying I'm not entirely sure but I
I do think this threat is particularly
interesting if you want to check it out
geoc confirmed on twt and I would say
this look and as I said I'm no expert
but I have looked at a number of these
things just through my previous work uh
in the
government to me that looks like and you
got to remember a lot of these are
homemade um Rockets Rockets right so it
looks like the Thruster probably broke
through the actual shell and then that
thrust pushed out the side of it and the
a lot of these Rockets cuz they're
homemade they're kinetic that means it
has to touch
it with force to be able to go off and
they're usually in the nose of this
thing and so the Thruster probably burst
out the side of the actual rocket and
then it fell down made kinetic contact
obviously with the hospital and that's
just a guess nobody quote me out there
try to Own Me On it later but it's just
a guess you confirm mentions I mean the
simple version is what you see when the
rocket ignites in midair is the
propulsion system breaking and the
payload is still active when it slams
into the ground exactly because those
the payload itself is generally they're
kinetic right and so if the if the if
the rocket and the booster go out then
it's going to wherever it falls it will
explode look I mean this is this is the
scary reality of War this is what false
flags are for a nation historically this
has happened several times will attack
itself because they they can use that
attack as justification look up the
years of lead in Italy it went on for
decades they it was just it was just V
false flags on each other the whole time
uh and a lot of people blame NATO I
think it was for interfering with that
and planing those false flags and little
little historical tidbit is in the very
beginning of of the years of lead and if
the the rumors of NATO being involved
are true the person in charge of that
group was General lenser who was the guy
who went to JFK with operation
Northwoods but there's always been the
question too of don't forget the war in
the Balkans right where you had the
shelling of the market which uh they had
blamed on the serbians and then it was
like well actually was that the kosovars
that had actually done that you know
there was a question around getting us
involvement going after that shelling uh
who actually had done it um not saying I
have the answer to that but that was one
no matter who did this though and there
if there were 500 people in that
hospital it's a war
crime and uh it's disgusting no
absolutely it's disgusting but it is you
know and we talked about this at the
outset it's very interesting is all
militaries have always had scops right
you know propaganda and things you know
trying to push them trying to push
messages and scops and trying to push uh
the population in the manner in which
they think about a conflict in a certain
direction but today it's so much
different because it's like to second to
Second you know this you know World War
II right or Vietnam or had scops it was
over a long trajectory period of time
right of trying to control the narrative
now it's just almost chaotic I think
that we're in a non-reality I think
we're Beyond reality right now I keep
calling it post reality and it's like
that that's like the totality of events
occurring both digital and physical
right as as the whole world is on fire
that's a great term for actually post
reality working on that I'm trying to
get it started so it's like share
modernism postmodernism reality post
reality we're beond because because
watching people debate decapitated
babies on Twitter within moments or or
or ghost of Kiev you know thing about
those debates is that it the idea is
that in some way if you can I say that
there's this kind of propaganda or that
kind of propaganda on one side or
another then that justifies your opinion
or perspective on the conflict and it
doesn't like propaganda Warfare is
propaganda Warfare it doesn't really
have anything to to do with what
actually is objectively going on I want
just point out real quick uh one of the
super chats Justin SLA says Max
Blumenthal has proven it was Israel I I
checked ma Max blumenthal's uh Twitter
history and I I've not seen any any
definitive information or anything
proving anything simply I have seen some
conjecture that the videos that are
putting out have an incorrect Tim stamp
which will have to be verified and I'm
also stating I am skeptical on the geoc
confirmed but I do think a long thread
from a geot tring with coordinates uh uh
non-war non-journalistic entity is just
being like we tracked the images we
looked at the the locations here's the
coordinates it's it's reasonably more
likely to be true however I I I will
remain skeptical I I don't know who did
this but it does seem in my opinion
based on everything I've read Hamas
likely had a rocket misfire I mean look
these are these are makeshift improvised
Rockets yes saying that that it misfired
is not unreasonable saying that Israel
with military Precision blew up a
hospital full of children that's a bold
claim that requires some B some
extraordinary it's possible it's
entirely possible it's entirely possible
yeah I mean this isn't like a patriot
battery firing it's like you know those
things don't miss fire right they go
where they're guided to I mean but Hamas
like you're saying it's makeshift rocket
I mean I think it's or it's Iranian
right don't the Iranians did it either
either way the the you know Israel is
operating with I think um what the
fourth strongest military in the world
they said I mean this is this is this is
Cutting Edge this is bleeding edge
weapons technology there can be
accidents there can be mistakes it just
means the probability of the accident
mistake is going to be on Hamas not in
Israel that's right and and and you know
look there was a statement put up by
someone saying that it was they said
Israel struck a hospital that was
operating as a terror base or whatever
and then the person deleted the tweet
that didn't mean anything to me I I
don't know right we don't know for sure
that's what's so weird is like any
reality you want to be true is will be
true for you on the internet you just
got to find it right everything you want
to be true is true which means then
nothing is true can you can product to
of like the the relativist approach to
everything where it doesn't matter what
the perspective is everything is is
equally valid which is essentially not
just post reality but post morality oh
which we are definitely a postoral and
and even though these things may or may
not be true we are learning how people
are reacting to what they think is true
which is also terrifying you know
because there some people want this
these things to be true no matter what
side it is well and the crazy thing too
is you have like the you know so many
people who are walking around carrying
trans flags being like I'm Pro Hamas and
you're like you you know they would kill
you they right they hate you as well as
me they don't hate you less because you
says with my theory that they are they
are certainly a death cult yeah
definitely a death cult going on I think
it's like
um they're they're the inversion of
logic right and I'm not trying to be
funny like you H how LGBT for Palestine
I mean that's releasing criminals and
arresting victims in New York If you
defend yourself you get arrested and if
you're a criminal you get released it's
it's it's Bizarro world it's it's an
inversion of what logic is cuz there's
no more distinction between parity and
reality
yeah there's no distinction between good
or bad because both are equally valid
depending on how you feel at the time
exactly so when people first saw Alex
Stein doing his routine I stand within
dude I love it but people on the right
thought he was a real person from
the it's hilarious so there there's no
more distinction which is is is funny
but it's insane I feel bad for the
Babylon be they try yeah but it's like
they're more prophetic right I mean they
can't do much at this point because
you'll see one of their headlines and
you're like oh but I just saw that in
the Washington Post I know just Blends
in it's the same yeah that's that's so
that so they made not the be they made
not life has become so absurd they have
to make it it's not satire but it seems
like it sounds like it yeah yeah and the
onion barely exists anymore I seen in
forever rest inace came true I think
we're I think we're laugh I think we're
laughing a bit too much let's get back
to
this good we got a story here from
Middle East i.net Israel Palestine War
jordanians tried to storm Israeli
Embassy after Gaza Hospital attack we
have this tweet lowkey online I'm not
sure who lowkey is uh host a podcast on
mint press news says the Israeli Embassy
in Jordan is on fire and this was posted
3:19 PM uh today so several hours ago
but uh this has been ongoing I I don't
know if we have uh yeah we have this
video here from the post millennial that
I'll play for you guys just a short
video showing what appears to be
thousands maybe tens of thousands of
people outside the us and Israeli
embassies and of course again the
reporting is that they've tried to storm
the embassy so uh look
man I don't see how we get we get we get
out of this without at least widespread
war in the region whether it involves us
or not I feel like CLE is going to it's
we we are not just going to be dragged
in we're going to like jump in which is
what we seem to be doing Jo Biden's
jumping in right now Will lindsy Graham
be on ground lindsy Graham Lindsey
Graham won't do anything lindsy Graham
I've been calling him the Anthony fouchy
of War
interest he's got his whole deal that
guy is crazy I can understand if our
interests are attacked and someone says
we should defend our interests fine I
will argue we should not have interests
in certain areas and so my argument
would be thus we should not be involved
for those reasons if the president is
attacked it's a tough position but for
Lindsey Graham to come out and say with
or without evidence the US should bomb
Iran is psychotic that is psychotic
bombing Iran would be a totally wacky
thing
it's insane I I he wants it I mean he's
going to make people will make money off
of war and he's probably one of those
people he's like buying a bunch of stock
in rathon
and I would point out just to be clear
is and some people might not remember or
know this but there are tens of
thousands of Palestinians living in
Jordan uh in refugee camps now for the
last several decades so this
there there is a huge Palestinian
presence in Jordan so perhaps and Jordan
isn't accepting them into their society
at large correct why are they not doing
that well they don't Lebanon either
they're also in refugee camps why are
they keeping these people in refugee
camps it's it's an interesting thing why
are they doing that well one of the main
reasons might be because of the I don't
know if I think is Hamas Sunni are they
Sunni is that correct or shiaas
isbah is Shia that's right
is Shia so that's what maybe the issue
with well I was going to say that may
have been the issue of them being Shia
going to Sunni country but if they're
both Sunni and they both have the same
alignment I don't know if Jordan is Shia
or Sunni and know that area is where in
Center in Sunni Sun yeah Jordan Sunni
and Hezbollah is Shia right that's
correct and that's what's interesting
about Hezbollah and Hamas being
friendlies because they're Sunni and
Shia and they disagree with fundamental
facts about their religion but that's
what I was wondering if why that was why
the people from from the West from Gaza
we're not being accepted but that is uh
I don't really know anything else beyond
that you know but obviously they have a
common enemy so think about Bashar al-
Assad right so he is an alawite and
alawites are an offshoot of sh uh Shia
Islam they're not in direct alignment
the alites with the Iranians but the
Iranians came in and supported them in
in that war right and so it's obviously
um relationship of convenience and I
mean they have a common common enemy
right we don't have a lot of Christian
sects going around fighting each other
ever since uh the British worked their
thing out with the Catholic Irish yeah
we don't see a lot of like interwar
between Christian groups as an Irish
Catholic I don't know if that's
completely worked out yet but uh you
know it's working out better than it is
yes yes no no no no it is working out a
lot better I have been giving that some
thought though like when you think about
it so here in the US have a lot of we've
seen all of these groups start
protesting in favor of Hamas essentially
um on college campuses and in Dearborn
Michigan and in a lot of City centers
we've seen that in Times Square you know
you see people out with cfas and
whatever and there's they're all being
supported in a lot of cases these are
people who are being supported by not
for-profits in the US you know so you
have not for-profits like care what is
it the cir c yeah they're supporting
this stuff they probably have an IRS tax
designation making them a charity so
that they can be funded and all I could
think of when I start thinking about
this and where's this money coming from
in the US to F fuel the protesters in
the US who are backing Hamas is the uh
Catholic churches in the 1980s um in the
US that would collect donations to
repair the roofs of the churches in
Ireland AKA going to Ira Rashida T has
tweeted out apparently um that Israel
did bomb a a Baptist Hospital killing
500 Palestinians doctors children and
patients and then blames the president
Brian kenin is criticizing her because
it's not confirmed but this is the point
I was making I mean it's already out
well she's a congresswoman so she must
be right she's a congresswoman yeah yeah
she has America's best interest at her
I'm sure that's why she's got that
Palestinian flag outside her office
right LGB she's got it's true so now
what's going to happen is the people who
who like her are going to say it's true
she said so that's it end of story yep
it doesn't matter what the truth is no
it's relative you since you brought it
up the interesting thing though about
Northern Ireland and I'm not going to go
down a rabbit hole on this is that they
did end up coming to through the Good
Friday agreements some type of formal
structure look if the people of Northern
Ireland now through referendum vote to
be to rejoin uh the Republic of Ireland
that's what's going to happen and the
British government is going to recognize
that and they were able to come up with
some type of uh political solution here
I have no I you're not going to get a
political solution here no no it's not
going to happen it's just not going to
happen this is this is scary stuff man I
mean if you're just on Twitter right now
if you're on X there's a lot of videos
flying around that are unconfirmed that
are going to lead us into very serious
conflict there's one post not confirmed
that a crowd in Turkey is trying to
break into a military base a US military
base and that the US they're saying the
US must respond and protect US Territory
I don't know if this is true I see magin
noaz R tweeted it from uh from Jason J
smart no idea where the video came from
but people are going to start seeing
these videos and it doesn't matter if
they get debunked later on you know
people people saw that's it they're not
going to look for the fact check and the
scary thing is Tim is that you have like
a
congresswoman who is feeding this social
media frzy who could if she wanted to go
get some classified briefing and
actually
understand probably much better than all
of us what's actually happening but she
has no interest in that she wants to
fuel the propaganda out there blind
support blind support is better than
support that has any knowledge of
anything that's going on because you can
tell them exactly what you wanted to
know you can you're the person who
controls information at that point
that's that's terrifying man yeah and
look I mean she's got her Flags out
there in front of her office I'm sure
Hamas is just waiting for the day to
raise the Palestinian and lgbtq flag uh
hey
thank you yeah yeah um it you
say's end it does seem weird that she is
a sitting congresswoman who is going
after one of our allies on Twitter that
seems bizarre yeah well she's an
anti-semite she does hate she's like a
classic Jew hater that is true we have a
number of them in Congress it turns out
I look look guys you know the left would
come out and say everyone on the right
is fascist and that is clearly false
because you can't call Dave Smith Trump
supporter because he's critical of trump
but they tried doing it when he was on
he was on Fox Business I think with
Kennedy and they were like you Trump
supporter like I don't support Trump
what are you talking about but when you
were looking specifically at Rashida tay
with the Palestinian flag blaming Israel
for something that's unconfirmed and the
involvement of of the DSA their support
for the like overt support for
Hamas yet we're not being cute when she
say she's anti-semitic that's just like
a confirmed statement to no it's just
that's just a fact yes she is Rashida
Talib so is ilhan Omar yes now hold on
AOC called for surgical I'm sorry
precision and intelligence to deal with
Hamas I was actually kind of impressed I
was like I don't know if I agree
precision and intelligence not not two
words I usually associated with her AOC
AOC is getting a lot of flack for for uh
for this because she's calling for a
ceasefire and I I I don't know why it's
like the the hate against her right now
is just pure tribalism yeah okay a
ceasefire she she uh asked about on CN
she's like this goes both ways Hamas is
firing Rockets into Israel we want it to
stop she's not saying Israel should just
not respond to the attack saying Hamas
needs to stop too right I can certainly
understand Israel saying we're going
after the military leaders and then
aoc's basic assessment which again she's
getting ragged on for was Collective
punishment is not a good is not good and
may destabilize the region Hamas must be
dealt with but we need military
intelligence and precision and I was
like AO went on television and said that
we should provide intelligence to
surgically strike and and assassinate or
execute Hamas leaders and and she's
getting Rag by Republicans I'm like what
what what is she supposed to say
indiscriminately bomb hospitals I don't
understand like she's giving what would
probably be a typical Republican answer
military surgical strikes on Hamas
leadership and she's getting raged I'm
like I don't know what to say to that
yeah
tribalism sometimes she is right just
recently I had agreed with her on uh her
UFO assessment when she was like uh
basically I think this is her saying it
we give billions of dollars to a lot of
Corporations with no oversight and
they're creating things that we might
not know about yeah and that's I'm like
I agree AOC that's actually not too dumb
I agree I tried I tried writing a story
about her and then I think they Googled
me I reached out to her team they're
like never mind I was this close I I I'm
wondering when the left is going to come
after AOC for saying Hamas must be dealt
with yeah she's out of the squad and she
and she like she didn't Lally say we
need surgical strikes to remove
leadership she says Hamas must be dealt
with and then she's asked how and she
goes perhaps with Military Intelligence
or precision and it's just like she's
basically saying too many civilians are
dying in Israeli air strikes they need
to be more precise in who they're
targeting and it's like Fair that's
that's more that's more Pro military
than I get coming from AOC right yeah I
mean the Striking thing though you know
through all of this yes we need to go
after Hamas they must be destroyed we
must go after the leadership they we
can't have the types of attacks on
Israel where's the Secretary of State
dealing with Egypt to get these
civilians out of there I mean has
anybody seen the Secretary of State I
mean I guess he's supposed to go over
there I don't right I don't never see
he's been over there he had a meeting he
had like an eight hour meeting yesterday
talking to people if you go to the state
department he is in is he's traveling to
Israel Jordan cutter Bahrain Saudi
Arabia UAE and Egypt he's trying to to
get all this stuff sorted out I don't
agree with blinkin on pretty much
anything but that's where he is he's
over there and he's the one who
announced that Biden was going to be
coming by but you know what I think is
that they have dragged their feet on
those types of relationships because
Trump is the guy that did the Abram
Accords right and so that was such a
great idea the Abraham Accords yeah and
and they have I think not wanted to
solidify and strengthen that agreement
that Trump were he not Donald Trump
would have received the Nobel Peace
Prize for doing something like that he
was not there were a couple people
nominated him I I recall yeah I mean to
be able to get uh Arab Nations like that
to be able to recognize and normalize
relations with the state of Israel is a
huge accomplishment and I think that
they've dragged their feet on that
accomplishment because they don't want
it to be cemented in place and now we're
paying the price for that because I
would imagine they've not uh kept up the
pressure in terms of normalization of
those um uh interactions in between
those two countries the most notable
thing I've seen blinkin do recently is
like play guitar at uh the White House I
don't know if anybody saw that I missed
that one entirely yeah he's he's
actually not bad at Guitar really yeah
is he as good at guitar as lizo was on
James Madison's I I I I think he's
better he did he twerk uh no but I think
he's playing like jazz or Blues he's
actually pretty good all right
interesting yeah right I think the the
the Abraham Accords were so
underreported I remember talking to
people about them who were like on the
left and they're like we never heard
anything about that and they you know
they're only watching CNN and NBC but
I'm like they were obviously
purposefully underreported they couldn't
give Trump anything no no and remember
they said oh we're going to have War uh
when Trump moves the embassy to
Jerusalem it's going to be you know holy
war it turned out okay turned out okay
actually worked out aren't we glad we
don't have the embassy in Tel Aviv right
now right my goodness I want to pull up
this tweet that I just saw this is from
uh Jeremy Frankl for anyone in Texas
media he says Hilton Hotels will be
hosting a conference for Hamas
supporters in Houston organizes in the
US campaign for Palestinian rights
notoriously proud Jew haters Rashida Tay
Linda sarur Mark Lamont Hill and several
others he says call h Hilton Hotels to
voice your objection remind them they're
breaking their own policy they say in
compliance the Patriot Act as well as
International anti-terrorism rules
Hilton does not support organizations
that engage in Terrorist activities or
involved in any Act dangerous to human
life that are a violation of the
criminal laws of any country where we
operate uh I'm just going to outright
say Don't call Hilton Hotels and
complain about leftists having their
conference that's not a good idea and
I'll explain exactly why I would like to
see all the videos of Rashida T at a pro
Hamas rally explaining why she supports
terrorism so that I can show my liberal
family members and say see that's the
importance of free speech so to see
conservatives be like how dare they
support this we must site the Patriot
Act to get them banned no no no no no no
no no I am I am tired of going to a
liberal and being like did you know that
rashita t said X prove it I'm like well
I can't find it because they censor it
no no no I want just like when the DSA
had that meeting where they were like
yelling about pronouns and everyone's
screaming over clapping I want those
videos to exist please don't don't get
this event canel you know what happened
that we had um you know the world
professional association for transgender
Health they had a meeting in Montreal
like last year or something and we had a
reporter undercover at that meeting um
who was you know streaming the videos
cuz they had streaming but only if you
had like registered and whatever
streaming the videos and all of that
stuff and when we published a bunch of
those videos and when we wrote down with
no analysis just exactly the things that
these people said about how unic should
be a gender identity for children wow
and how the chapter on how children can
identify as Unix had a lot of research
gathered from child porn website about
Unix right like this is what they were
talking about um the people who we
quoted who gave their talk at w paath
with pride and joy um and inclusivity
they came after us with a legal letter
saying like you can't write down and
publish what we said and we're like but
you you said it though this is why lives
of Tik Tok get in trouble you did say it
and we're going to publish it just
showing what they said they hate
themselves though because it's all a
projection not to make light of any of
this but mentioning Patriot Act and do
you think somebody like wrote Into the
patriot act like why don't we ban
terrorism conferences
like what the terrorists try to have
conferences but the the idea that having
a conference in support of Palestine
because they're not saying literally
Hamas but we know it kind of is but like
either way a group of people gathering
at a at a hotel for a conference is a
First Amendment protected activity
that's the right to Peaceable assembly
now saying that you want people to call
them call the Hilton and get them banned
is not government encroachment on speech
it's still just a bad strategy we we
want all the videos in the world of
these people being anti-semitic so that
it will be without a doubt then when
when it comes to the 2024 elections you
can play these videos on Loop you know
what you do you take the videos of them
speaking and you run them as ads on
Facebook then you're going to have your
liberal Aunt being like what's this
video of Rashid oh my what she's saying
what and you'll be like oh didn't know
she hated the Jews they'll say it was AI
wasn't really her but I mean then fine
make that the battle the point is let
them say it yep yeah I mean think about
the classic case right remember there
was this Nazi organization ACLU defended
them so they could so they could have
their March down the street SK and and
yeah exactly SK Illinois and ski
Illinois and it was shocking for the
American people shocking and it's awful
but people saw that and were like
this is wrong it's terrible and they had
an informed decision about their kind of
moral judgment about these issues which
is which is good that's a good thing yep
no idea should be suppressed I want to
hear everything yeah I I agree and I
think that the American people are smart
enough to be Discerning and figure
things out for themselves I hope so
especially if maybe we do you know that
would be nice it would help things out
maybe a little bit yeah um I agree
though I don't think that we should be
surprised ing speech I think that people
should gather they have the the right to
gather and do that and the other thing
too is as soon as you start taking away
people's rights you know as they're
enshrined in the Bill of Rights then
they start coming for yours we had a
situation recently Andy no who's with
post-millennial he was giving a speech
he was giving a talk in Richmond and uh
a bunch of activists didn't want him to
speak because he exposes activists for
you know being pretty awful so they
didn't want him to speak they kept
calling everywhere that his talk got
scheduled
to get it canell and the Marriot Hotel
where it was finally scheduled to speak
canel his talk you know and they had to
find another location so I don't see any
reason to get people's talks cancelled
no matter what they're talking about
right yeah and it also forces people to
meet and discuss these things
underground which then generally leads
to pretty dangerous activity right right
when when I was teaching uh journalism
fiction all this stuff I wanted the
students to be uh to experience ideas
outside of their typical you know
worldview right because I would tell
them you need to uh let your the immune
system of your ideas build up because if
they don't experience these ideas these
horrible ideas and when they do
encounter them in the real world they'll
just collapse their immune system will
die right you have to know how you feel
about these bad ideas you know tweak
your ideas here and there but if you
keep suppressing stuff yeah it'll just
fester in the dark and come back yeah
and you see so much of this right ster
sterilization of History so under the
Obama Administration they said we're
going to remove the Confederate flags at
Gettysburg and it's like people aren't
there maybe somebody is but generally
people aren't there to celebrate the
Confederate flags it's actually
something did happen there a historical
event that literally set the course of
this country yeah it's kind of important
for people to understand and know what
took place there right and if you're not
confronted with that those ideas and the
Confederacy stood for and what it was
doing and why this war happened and what
it looked
like young people get confronted with
this later in life and it's as you're
saying it just it falls away that
immunization that you said that they
need to have yep well because you need
to know how to defend your ideas you
need to know how to argue the best
points of your opposition just in order
to you know secure your own ideas and
make your own arguments as cohesive as
possible yes yeah you don't know what
you think until you start arguing with
someone who disagrees with you or
reading text that counters your view um
you just don't know exactly and look if
there's for some people the imagery of
the Confederate flag I'm sure is highly
offensive maybe it you know makes them
feel terrible when they see it it's not
most supposed to make you feel good
right um you're supposed to be
confronted with these things so you know
how to respond to it and form opinions
about it and things like that I mean
this is if you go down the rabbit hole
of everything that offends me then we
have to take off the table and everyone
gets a vote on that then what are you
left with right not very much no no
history's been flattened you know I grew
up uh outside of West Point uh the
military academy and um we have the
shell of the atom bomb in the museum and
every summer we have like thousands of
Japanese coming to visit the the bomb
and they take pictures with it and it's
like they're going to witness something
truly horrific right right and uh if you
keep getting rid of these things you
won't feel it like the way you're
talking about you know when I walk
battlefields and you like antium and
you're like 20,000 guys died there you
feel like this crazy History of Violence
that happened there and that's you know
pretty much everywhere in this in this
country well it' be like if you went to
Normandy obviously Germans died there
there is a section for them my
grandfather fought in uh World War II he
got shot in the face in Germany and I'm
sure there and I know there are there
gravestones that have swastikas on them
right now I I think we need to see that
we need to know that that happened right
I it's not that I obviously don't
support the swastika right but this is a
horrific thing that happened in human
history and for us to be able to
confront it and learn from it yeah
that's the thing that I think is like
lost upon the younger generation is that
like you and even my generation the
Millennials is kind of where it started
but you have to understand history to to
understand history you have to know
where you came from other you're going
to make the same mistakes like the
common adage goes if you don't remember
history you don't know history you're
doomed to make their mistakes or like if
you it's just it's just a thing that
everyone I think should know but I'm
shocked at how people actually know that
you go and see these things it's not
comfortable sure all these things in
history are not comfortable and if you
want to talk about them then you have to
be willing to to face it you know what I
mean you can't just run away from
everything and hide it and say oh this
do make me feel good too bad not
everything makes you feel good A A lot
of people have like a very black and
white view of History too you know like
you look at the Civil Wars like you know
you make understand Sherman as the hero
for the total war but if you really look
at what Sherman did there's a lot of
crazy things he did pretty bad stuff I
consider him our first adom bomb you
know the way he went down and like
destroyed everything and uh you know
there were people work there were
soldiers under him who massacred freed
slaves cuz they were upset they were
following them while they were doing the
trail uh you know the march of the sea
right yeah so it's nothing's easy but
you got to understand that nothing's
easy you know it can't just be flattened
and condensed into this very simple
history that's going to and that's a
great point is that it's it's not black
and white it's complex right and human
interaction is particularly War it is
complex and there's lots of different
interest motivations and all these other
things that happen terrible things on
both sides right I mean and I'm quoting
the guy uh mamera who happened to be
involved with um the firebombing with
lame in Japan he said had we lost we
would have been deemed and we were
acting as war criminal
yeah true and that's that's MAA saying
that right and but it was a total war
right they were trying to inflict Total
War on us and we inflicted Total War on
them and then same for Sherman you know
he said war is hell and like people the
idea of hell has been watered down but
legit hell I saw a good quote it said
war is not hell war is war and hell is
hell because in hell everyone who's
there is is guilty everyone there
deserves it and in war everyone there is
innocent yeah exactly Fair yeah that is
fair so war is worse than hell in there
a lot of way let's tell Sherman that
let's dig up William Tuma I mean Sherman
was kind of a bad guy oh he was a
miserable man he didn't like black
people he he he wanted to destroy the
South he fetishized vience mercilessly
merciless that was brutal yeah it's
crazy so I I I just looked it up I think
even the postm has it yeah they set fire
to the US Embassy in in Beirut the US
Embassy US Embassy yeah numerous tweets
saying the US embassy's been uh fire in
Iraq they're outside as he chanting
America's the greatest evil the post
millennial tweeting Hezbollah supporter
set fire outside US Embassy in Beirut
I've seen some tweets that uh they've
pulled the flag the US flag down our
place with the Palestinian flag a lot of
this is hard to confirm I'm just seeing
a lot of it I mean there's there's a
video it's all Breaking right now yeah
this is all Breaking right now right now
oh my god when I got in the I'm getting
like phone calls from one of my writers
like what's up I'm like I can talk to
you soon God I I hope they get our
people out of there oh for sure I'm
praying they get our folks out of there
um out of the embassy out of the embassy
what why do you think they haven't
evacuated them so far just from
precedent set is there like is there an
issue where there's like um is there
like an intelligence failure here where
we just had no idea that this was going
to happen how did we not know that this
was going to happen we saw that was um
being talked about in Israel and people
were criticizing
Netanyahu um for you know having this
had happened you had what is it shinb I
think Shin shinb had taken
responsibility for the
failure of you know just not knowing
that this was going to happen there was
some talk that they knew within a few
hours that maybe something was happening
and they didn't follow it up didn't you
say there was a report that was pulled
like a week ago about getting out of the
embassy yeah so last was it La it must
have been last week time has no meaning
um but it must have been last week um
and I was looking at reporting and you
saw on Twitter there were like maps of
like uh Hezbollah shooting of rockets
into Northern Israel a lot of people are
posting this map a lot of people who's
reporting I usually am like oh well if
they have it I'm going to start there
and then dig from there um and it turned
out to be fake I went to the AP and I
was like okay the AP has it maybe we can
maybe we can run a story about how this
is happening as soon as I finished
writing the story and we were about to
publish it it was like ready to go I
checked back at the AP and their
reporting on it was gone and the maps
turned out to be fake and it just wasn't
and they were saying that they the uh US
Embassy in beut had been evacuated and
it wasn't I I want to pull up the story
we have this from The Daily Mail this is
this is they're so fast this is the
headline they running US Embassy in
Lebanon is set on fire as thousands of
pro Palestinian riers waving Hezbollah
banners in circle the compound before
security DS of them in tear gas ryer
plants flag in fence as day of
unprecedented anger gets underway so
this is the the official reporting US
Embassy under attack I I certainly hope
they they that are they get our people
out of here I mean I don't I don't know
what Biden thinks he's going to
accomplish going into the region right
now at this degree of escalation yeah
but I certainly hope that our our
presence there gets our people out of
these embassies and maybe it's time we
just say see you later well and to
Libby's point though in terms of the
intelligence I mean look at the open
source intelligence here uh we have a
potentially escalating conflict the
United States president is coming to
visit and we just moved two uh strike
carrier groups into the region
perhaps we should have thought maybe uh
there could be an issue with our Embassy
in Lebanon which is essentially
controlled by Hezbollah
right like it seems like there's been a
just a ton of intelligent failures for
the past few
weeks or maybe they're not failures or
maybe not I I I I agree with Max
Blumenthal he said if this was an
intelligence failure on the part of
Israel this Max is is is very pro pro
Palestine and his view is that Israel
would never be humiliated in this way
they wouldn't allow it they wouldn't
allow one of their soldiers to be taken
because it puts them in such a weak
position so I see these arguments I saw
a clip from Charlie Kirk that there's an
argument that it benefits Israel to a
great degree to have allowed this to
happen but I think the detriment to
Israel for this happening the obvious
detriment for the civilians dying but
even politically is is it doesn't make
sense that they were yeah I I I don't
agree with that I think part of the
things and we've talked about this for
is how cheap and sophisticated
technology is now so Hezbollah and Hamas
in particular they have drones they have
the ability to see where people are
moving you can buy infrared cameras you
can I mean so they've been tracking and
there was an article out there about
they knew exactly where one of these
Israeli intelligence centers was just
right over the border that were supposed
to be monitoring this kind of activity
and took them out immediately and they
knew when those guys were coming when
they were going because they've been
using drones and things of that nature
to be able to to track that type of
thing and that's where you know you
you're always talking about this
qualitative military Edge qualitative
qualitative at some point
quantitative does become qualitative and
where you're able to have a lot of
assets and this is where the Iranians
swarm technology uh or swarm tactics
rather around US Naval vessels and
things like that are so dangerous sure
yeah look we got an aircraft carry what
are you going to do if you got 20,000
boats coming at it are you going to
shoot them all EX like piranhas they're
little and yappy kill you you start to
think too about um how the Americans won
in the revolution I know we had like
French support and all of that stuff but
we also kind of invented Grill of
warfare a little bit you know yes that's
a big deal yes so if you have and and
the difference too is that American
soldiers are not ideologically driven
here um but we're fighting an
ideological enemy that believes fully
that the best thing that they can do is
die as as Martyrs to their cause right
they teach their children that I mean
there were um there were TV shows like I
forget what it was called I know I have
it on here somewhere in one of these
5,000 tabs I have open but um but there
were TV shows that were running in like
2007 to
2014 in Gaza and the West Bank that were
produced in the West Bank at TV studios
and it was uh like cartoon like a like a
like sort of Mickey Mouse type of
character yeah and it was teaching them
that being jihadis was their best option
for life it uh you know the the
extremism of this islamist ideology and
the way that it really changed I think
when the terrorists started uh pushing
it fully wellis it's really yeah I mean
it's really destructive obviously it's
really destructive but um how do you
fight someone that wants to die exactly
right well in you know that ideology you
mentioned to bring that full circle back
to what we were talking about just a
moment
ago there's people on colleges campuses
chanting from The River To The Sea
that's so terrifying from The River To
The Sea what does that mean that means
the annihilation of the Jewish state of
Israel that means the
annihilation of the Jews in that land
yeah that's what that means from The
River To The Sea yes it does and so that
that that's why you ask any leftist
they're not going to give you a straight
answer what would happen if the security
fencing around Gaza was removed and
Israel said everyone here you can just
go do whatever you
want the left knows the right will say
it explicitly oh yeah they'll go and
start killing citizens and civilians
right they'll call them settlers the the
left will just hem and haw and deflect
because they know what the answer is
yeah you know and I and I think the
reason why you get this answer um from
leftist which is they'll try and Dodge
it they can't publicly say oh we know
what will happen and then gloat in their
calling for what would eventually be
civilian deaths they also know that they
publicly state that Hamas should not do
it the leftists are going to attack them
saying you think they should bow down to
settlers blah blah blah the left really
has they they know most people oppose
what they're proposing and they know the
left would take issue if they reject
what the left is proposing right so they
have they can't answer the question
honestly yeah it's terrifying thinking
about the gorilla the gorilla Warfare
stuff too is like it made me think of
Viet
sure and it was so bad with the gorilla
Warfare over there that we had to seed
the clouds to try to start water like
rain to fall to to destroy their their
Pathways to fight them you know fighting
that kind of stuff is impossible the the
the craziest thing that I the scops of
Vietnam my my one of my favorite
military Concepts when they would play
they put speakers in the jungle playing
the sound of a wailing Vietnamese
Soldier saying why did I fight why
didn't I go home to be with my family
I'm trapped forever flee while you can
don't be trapped like me because the
Superstition among the Vietnamese was
that if you weren't given a proper
burial you were doomed to wander the
Earth so they would play these spooky
ghost sounds that were so effective the
South Vietnamese would flee as well so
they had to stop doing it but in that
regard that's old school that's you know
50 some OD years ago the psychological
operations we're going to see now are
going to be all social media
based and they've been happening for
some time yep so I mean look these
videos we're watching we are we are at
the point it could be now that these
videos are AI generated yes and we are
like wow look at this atrocity and the
photos and everything we had the
argument over whether the photo was a
generated already this is this is a
horror show yeah I mean the United
States can put out videos of anything
they want using AI yep and what are you
going to do every journalist just agrees
with it and then there's no journalism
anymore yeah how are you we're in that
you know that is a that is a tough spot
it's like that evil and W novel scoop
where journalists just show up to the
war zone and the one guy shows up to the
war zone and he's like where's the war
and everyone's like sh there isn't
really one wow just chill well I
remember this was a big uh there was a
big social media troll campaign several
years ago where people were taking old
photos of like military convoys and then
tweeting that I can't believe this is
happening and they were saying something
in like Ohio I can't remember which
state it was and then I'm on Twitter and
I'm seeing all these posts where they're
like dude it's happening now everyone
was in on it it was a game but a lot of
people didn't understand and thought it
was real MH you see you see a video of
like a tank driving down the street then
you see like police pushing people back
and everyone was claiming that all these
things were one incident that happened
when it was just random videos stuff put
together maximum maximum absurdity with
unbridled horror on the internet and uh
that is what is driving me insane being
on Twitter every time I open it up cuz I
see you know something has been
confirmed then that immediately that
that thing has been canceled out uh yeah
it's crazy and I still don't want to
suppress that the bad information I I
think it just needs to be out there so
we can can fight it because I see other
people calling for it to be somehow
suppressed or have Twitter step in which
I also think is ridiculous well dude I
guarantee like the operation T was
talking about was called operation
wandering soul and I guarantee if
anyone's looking into it I don't know if
the chat is is interested but if if you
don't think that there's something like
that going on or at least numerous
operations that are going on right now
to both combat uh this new AI uh I guess
we'll call misinformation and to create
new misinformation as well because you
know the best defense is a good offense
then you're kidding yourself there are
definitely things going on right now
that you don't know about and none of us
know about and we can't speak anything
about and neither neither could you I'm
sure as well we don't know and just the
knowledge of the AI stuff happening
makes it so people are there's so
there's
WID buil in yeah yeah exactly it's
already part of the operation just to
know that this is going on it's already
one of the things they're aware of right
one of these operations that's going on
yeah it's well that's why the videos so
many of the videos are like so
incredibly emotional you know because if
you are first struck with an emotion and
you're going to react in a you know in a
way that that corresponds to that and
you're not going to question it first
when they get you with your feelings
first that's when you really have to
watch out and be careful that's
something we talk about at post
millennial all the time with the social
media team and we're all like okay you
just got to chill you got to stay frosty
you got to like keep your W about you
that's something actually Jack pesobic
said a while ago he was like Stay Frosty
and we're like that is the mot nice Jack
that's good I know where you're getting
that my friend all right everybody we're
going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and head over to
timcast.net hang out with like-minded
individuals and discuss today's news as
well as enjoy the shows that they've
launched pre-show after show Etc we are
now going to read what y'all have to say
and answer some of your questions Clint
Torres with the number one Super Chat
saying howdy people howdy howdy howdy
all right kalishnikov says and what
happens when China moves into Taiwan we
will be spread thin across three fronts
not to mention our collapsing border the
fourth front well and all three of those
are the ones that have been uh volatile
in the past 100 years so Eastern Europe
the Middle East and the Pacific Theater
if you will uh we're going to be in deep
trouble if that's what's going on
especially if we don't even have any
control over our own nation and our own
people don't have any sense of being
American or patriotism and nationalism
has been vilified we have a real problem
that that's 100% correct and couldn't
agree with you more one kind of food for
thought for the uh viewers and listeners
is just remember the United States has
never gone to war with a country equal
or larger in economy and
population and oh that's interesting we
have never beat and defeated a country
that is by population an economy either
equal or larger than
us wow so you're saying that the United
States has picked fights with a bunch of
little guys and then now I mean we we
were just generally one of the bigger
developed guys and now China's On The
Rise mhm when we are on the decline
Ian says anyone else not getting any
live stream notifications for the last
couple of weeks you're not the only one
yeah you're not I also have it on my
phone and I got no notification today so
I hear you it's funny when my family
members are like why didn't I get the
notification I click it every day yeah
like for people who watch every day well
look the only reason this show Works two
reasons one people choose to come and
watch it you YouTube suppresses us just
I just no question about it I mean
people will will be like the stream
doesn't even appear on the YouTube
channel itself
and they'll only find it through like
someone else sharing it or someone
posting the link so I I I think the main
reason this show exists is because y'all
have decided it should and have shared
it or become members at
timcast.net videos at 4 p.m. one day I'd
talk about war or whatever it would get
30,000 and I'd be like okay that is
clearly not right and because I'd get
messages from people being like I can't
find it I can't find it because people
were looking for it that's how you know
so I I think we're fortunate enough that
we have Word of Mouth and people share
the show yeah likewise what do we got
scody Johnson says what if the Deep
state is sending Joe over knowing
something bad will happen in order to
escalate the conflict that's the
conspiratorial fear but either way you
don't need a conspiracy for it the issue
is there is a great risk to Joe Biden if
something happens it will escalate
escalate the conflict so it doesn't
matter if anyone's wanting to do it it's
happening like the motives behind it are
IR relevant Biden is going there he
could get hurt we could get drawn into
World War II please just
no for Brit says I heard Disney is
trying to meet with Paramount to try and
stop the South Park episode coming out
because it is a threat to their business
model can't wait to watch it I don't
know I don't know that sounds kind of
weird I can say that uh I checked out
the season premiere of Rick and Morty
without Justin Ryland okay so for those
that don't understand Rick and Morty I
think it debuted as as like a Top IMDb
100 show meaning like it was shockingly
popular among a lot of people Justin
royland does the voice of Rick and Morty
as well as many others like Mr Poopy
butth hole Yeah they they fired him
after he was
false it's it's all just potty humor but
he was falsely accused he was he was uh
I believe it's fair to say exonerated
yeah uh and and finally but he was fired
from all of his voice acting roles I
don't all of them but many of them these
big Network roles they launched the new
season without him and it was the cringe
cringiest thing ever I just there's like
in the opening scene Morty says one
thing and then just get up and gets up
and leaves the room like dude he's a
titular character he's in the intro and
then uh the mom vo by someone else is
like Morty can you go to the dish or
something like then he's like he just
gets up and walks out without saying
anything and I'm like get out of here
and then it's just like the person
voicing Rick does not do a good job I'm
sorry like you can't you can't it's
obvious yeah and so the whole episode is
like other characters and Rick barely
talks I'm like dude cancel the show you
fired the magic behind it you're done
dude it's like Seth McFarland not doing
the voices for any of his shows anymore
you lose like you lose a large portion
of the people on the show that he voices
as well and you wonder why it doesn't
feel the same that's why imagine if
you're trying to watch Family Guy and it
was Sheamus voicing
pet everyone just instantly understands
how awful that would be could you
imagine somewhere Sheamus is like
squeezing his fist and like punching a
pillow looking at all his
spoons James come
back well Sheamus will be back soon uh
he just abandoned us so we make fun of
him for it all right he deserves it but
yeah anyway that was my opportunity to
rag on how awful Rick and Morty was oh
man oh man I I I watched a little bit of
it want to watch the rest of it because
it's just now it's not Justin Ro it's no
what's his name the guy who writes the
show I can't remember his name um but
the other guy that writes the show I
can't remember name Dan Haron Dan Harman
yeah it's basically like his show now
it's his narrative completely there else
yeah exactly it was I I don't even I Roy
made the show it it was just hilarious
that Morty it's the show's called Rick
and Morty and Morty just like in the
first in the opening has like a half a
sentence and then gets up and leaves
yeah right I'm like okay we understand
what's happening that happens a lot when
they pull like somebody good from a show
like pulled TJ Miller off Silicon Valley
and it became unwatchable oh that's
right right he got accused too yeah he
got accused of something stupid and it's
like he was the funniest character on
the show the way that everyone
interacted with him was what made that
show funny I wonder if we can make a a
show called like Nick
and shorty B
shortyy yeah Nick and shorty and I'll
I'll see if Justin Ryland will that
would be
incredible be incredible and get TJ
Miller on there and TJ that'd be really
funny adri Curry
Sayan oh get Adrian Curry on it too get
Rosanne and Adrian Curry and TJ Miller
that would be awesome that would be
amazing I would watch the hell out of
that show I don't even know what it's
about I don't even care I would watch it
it would we would we would just
literally it would be like Silicon
Valley rosean and Rick and Morty all
combined into one show as a joke to make
fun of the fact and it would be like a
great show like that would be cuz all
those people are so funny I mean yeah
those are genuinely hilarious people
that would really be killer it's sad to
see Rick Morty go that way because I'm
not even a big fan of the show but to
see it go this way just sucks they
should have just canell it yeah they
should have I mean look it's on season
seven shows they're getting on in years
I mean Simpsons had nine Good Seasons 10
years old now basically 10 years old
yeah that's crazy I remember when I
worked for vice they had a painting on
the wall in Williamsburg for Rick and
Morty I was like that looks stupid what
is that like what's going on and then it
debuted and it was a huge show like
people were people loved it that's just
the stupidest thing ever they thought
they could replace the guy who made the
show just you can't do it sorry man yeah
pointless all right Bullseye Ben says
hello timcast crew one of our members
recently lost her brother randomly if
anyone here can assist with funeral
costs please search for Noah Sunday it's
not letting me link the post to GoFundMe
because you should use give send go and
not
GoFundMe yeah GoFundMe is not good they
they they cancel people so you know is
there is there an online list of like
these corporations that we shouldn't be
using
could I mean I assumed everybody knew
not to use GoFundMe and to use giv go
instead right yeah Daniel says I can't
download any of your content on Apple or
Spotify for a week does anyone have this
problem H what I've heard anything about
it I not heard anything about that yeah
like we upload everything looks normal
to us yeah it seems normal to us so I
we'll I'll look but and we haven't done
anything like supporting Hamas so I
don't see why the machine would try and
take us down maybe we're not we're not
pro intervention enough they don't want
those anti inter may not like Pro homas
enough yeah oh yeah I mean I think then
then you'll be able to get your message
out no no I I actually think that if if
you made a pro Israel Pro intervention
podcast you'd be number one across the
board because every big Tech platform
would promote you yeah they they're
they're they're the the farle are
getting gutted by supporting
Hamas yeah the war machine is is pretty
happy with the fact that uh uh there's
people rallying for war that's why AOC
is changing her tune to be fair though
oh right no yeah absolutely is going
full Pelosi right she's an next Pelosi
full Pelosi that's the name of her show
Pelos Pelosi wow it's got those like
bikini shots from
[Laughter]
Italy oh I can't wait great all
right I was thinking pants suits
honestly you said full Pelosi and I
immediately thought full is like the
naked people right let's read some more
we got BR Tidwell says Tim your Discord
has been holding house members
accountable for speaker vote Sammy
deserves a
that's correct right on what are they
doing they're calling people um I don't
know I've just heard about this since we
went live but uh we'll be having Sammy
Sammy from football or Sammy football I
think it is I don't remember her name oh
I met her in Miami yes cool so come hang
out in the members only show and we'll
be talking to our our members timcast
members on the on the Discord yeah
Charlie Kirk posted the phone numbers of
the 20 reps who did not vote for Jordan
what what are they I I there's a there
we'll we'll talk about this in the uh
members only yeah bit spicy but
Brian insulting members of Congress is
just so good vote tomorrow 11:00 a.m. 11
11 yep okay that's that's actually
perfect timing because it fits perfectly
with my recording schedule so you know
that's why they did it great they were
like records around then can we can we
get the vote in around then so we work
the schedule like thanks guys I was
recording something I was like on air
today we were doing a pre-record with
Laura Trump who was on the show I
thought that was very cool when she's
great but we were doing the show and
recording and at the same time there was
the vote and I kept like looking down at
my computer being like don't look at
your computer they're voting don't look
okay don't don't look you know you know
what I think These Guys these guys who
voted against Jordan just did it so that
now scalise or whoever you know Jordan
is going to go to them and say what do
you want and they're going to be like
okay you give me these things and I'll
vote for you that's what it is because
there there's no reason to vote against
Jim Jordan I mean like are they going to
go to their constituents and be like I
didn't want the house to have a speaker
they're going to be like dude come on
you're wasting everyone's time nobody
wants Jim Jeff well a lot of these guys
though are in Democrat areas yeah yeah
like New York so maybe maybe maybe they
do want you know I don't I don't know
you know I support Jim Jordan for
speaker I think everybody should be
voting for him and put him in there I
Jim Jeff I like what you did was a cool
mental I I think there's uh I think
there's a lot of bad blood in the
conference there there's just a lot of
bad blood yeah it doesn't it does seem a
little fractured well you talked to
Congress gates for a long time I mean
Matt Gates is the is is our best member
of Congress no question and and yeah and
there's like probably a dozen or so that
are good and the rest is just there's a
reason why you don't know their names
and there there's a reason why you know
the names of some and not not others the
back benchers yeah yeah and and they
just might as well not be there at the
end of the day they all get a vote in
this you know and that's the the hurting
of the cats and look smaller venue I was
in the West Virginia state legislature
previously so I've had a little bit of
experiences with this because I was in
house leadership it's it's all person
for us it was all personality driven it
really was I mean we get people vote for
us or against it not not always based on
policy but more kind of voted
on do they like you right uh do they
feel like they can work with you is is
part of it and I I don't know if some of
them are going to be able to come off of
that I I don't know yeah it seems like a
lot of those people value
reputation over authenticity you know
and it's they're not there for that all
right Nick Mr corada says in Canada our
tax isn't hidden it's called the carbon
tax and it's 20% longtime listener and
OG panging member much love from Canada
sorry to hear you're from Canada I hope
you guys win your freedom though I do
shout out to the freedom truckers
Freedom Convoy carbon tax fake that's
like this whole carbon thing is fake
y the whole climate agenda is fake
you're made of carbon isn't that crazy
what huh You're Made Of carbon what do
they mean when they say they want to
eliminate the carbon footprint hey just
make you think doesn't it what do you
mean yeah all
right under says Tim has to ignore that
Marxist collectivists have won and
occupy the US McCarthy was right America
is experiencing oligarchic corporatism
perhaps but I don't understand why I can
say it 800 times people don't see
understand there is more than one
ideological attempted takeover in this
country there are probably tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
organized ideological groups but it is
the marxists who have gained the most
power Technically when you look at their
ideology there's no logic it makes no
sense wixon is the word one day then
it's women with a Y then women with an i
and then that's offensive and then it's
you must a woman there's there's no plan
that's why at first it was racism then
sexism then uh feminism then
intersection intersectional feminism
then total intersectionality then CR
critical theory and it keeps changing
because the left doesn't have anything
it it like people have said have tried
to figure out what woke means and I said
it is the current social Orthodoxy of
the left that's it there's nothing else
yes there's there's no underlying
principle because it changes how can you
say it's Marxist when they're Pro
foreign war and intervention right they
defy any logic and reasoning it's a
morphous yeah it's literally just what
we dis what what what the greater thing
is adhered to what what the social
Orthodoxy is yeah can we get clicks and
views from it than it is a good thing Y
and that that's why like they'll they'll
disagree with the right no matter what
right so you know the example I often
give is Hassan perer makes a video I say
he's completely right about this he
responds by insulting me telling me I'm
wrong because he has to do that yeah of
course that's what the left is are you
are you aligned with the social
Orthodoxy or not if you're not you're
bad and you're rightwing it's like
they've distilled the current good and
the current good is this above all it's
all it is so I think Ukraine the Ukraine
war is a really great example ukra the
war in Ukraine they all these leftists
support how does that happen for what
reason are they in favor of the US
intervention they have no reason yeah no
reasons if they were on social media and
uh look notice that every one of their
views aligns with what social media
permits and promotes H everything that's
all it is if you were to get rid of the
social media apparatus they would be
agreeing with whatever the television
said that's it so that's why I say this
ideology is promoted and pushed through
social media the not the universities
the universities or I should say the
universities promote and push it
obviously but it only has power because
these people think they can get clicks
and traffic on social media if the big
tech companies banned these people they
would change their tune in two seconds
which is why AOC is now saying we need
surgical strikes on Hamas because she
knows what Butters her bread and she
she's watching all the people saying Pro
look all these people who are pro
Palestine now supporting Hamas and
they're getting cancelled the Harvard
students who wrote The Letter being like
please no we made a mistake about this
social media told them black lives
matter is the winner support them so
they did but oopsie they were wrong the
power structure said no no no no not
this time AOC changes her tune and all
of a sudden she's like well we we have
to stop Gaza they're firing Rockets too
and Hamas must be dealt with Wow major
departure from the Democratic Socialist
of America who have outright promoted
and supported Hamas as resistance
Freedom Fighters and cheered in the
streets of New York for bombing
civilians not an exaggeration when the
woman said they fired rockets on Tel
Aviv they all cheered and screamed and
AOC has inverted her position why
because she knows who Butters her bread
the machine you you can't support this
and the people who are are losing their
jobs and like there a doctor in New York
got fired for cheering for this she went
on social media and she cheered for her
mosque she got fired watch
them change their tune overnight and now
they're going to say you know I always
did wonder about BLM whatever social
media tells them to support they will
well that happened to to a Air Canada
pilot got got suspended for being pro
Hamas as well they thought were thought
they were doing the right thing yeah
they thought they were doing the right
thing by hating Jews don't they always
think that was it a tweet like how was
it a tweet it on the intercom no there
were photographs of him at uh like
rallies with um
very detailed signs about how much he
hates Israel wow well in the way the
left is organized themselves you have to
remember is through the Cold War it was
very easy and binary right because the
Socialists the left it was class war
right that was the identifier that was
how they you know the proletariat and
blah blah blah blah bisi that's how they
organized themselves after the collapse
of the Soviet Union and the end of the
Cold War this is where we saw the rise
of identity politics how do you get more
power you create more identities right
and this is why we see this fractious
numbers of groups that they're trying to
wrap their arms around as it relates to
some type of grievance group that
they've brought into the fold but how
does it give you more power how does
having more identities it's because
there is a machine that will share your
posts with more people if you have more
keywords yes so look this look these
Vice articles up the the the hilarious
one I'll try and find it for the for the
uncensored where it's like black Trans
women of color fighting police brutality
exemplify black lives matter perfectly
and it's like wow they really crammed
everything into one headline there and
it's be so you make an article that says
racism is bad you'll get X views sexism
is bad y views it's not X Plus y if you
combine them it's x times y it's
exponential because what happens with
the social media algorithms is the more
hits you get then they exponentially
increase how much they they share your
content the algorthm on YouTube used to
function like this or uh I Believe
YouTube function like this if in the
first 10 minutes your video goes out it
hits more than 10% of your subscribers
and they click it then YouTube will
amplify 100 fold because they're like we
got we got a hot one here push this one
out they desperately want to make sure
that hot content kind that's that people
want to watch gets the most traffic and
makes the most money and content that is
bad gets pushed away so that viewers
stay on the platform and watch something
else so if you combine all the keywords
you are going to hit a wider swath of
users you're going to get more hits in
the first 10 minutes and the algorithm
will promote you exponentially further
right than if you just chose one so of
course if you said I like Trump yeah you
get a thousand views but if you put
Donald Trump is racist sexist anti-gay
Donald Trump Donald Trump go away well
now you got Trump three times you got
all these other buzzwords boom you're
getting promoted like crazy right all
right we got this from Gabriel Lopez he
says can Hamas Rockets even demolish
entire buildings if they can why aren't
Israeli buildings demolished iron D only
captures 90% some pass through do damage
but nowhere near demolition level on the
other other side half of Gaza is
demolished exactly like the hospital the
first question is was the hospital
demolished entirely I don't think that
was the case but was it don't no I don't
think so yeah I don't think it was
demolished entirely um it may have been
and that being said it may have been
Israel it may have been a strike from
Israel that was targeting terrorists
that were using the hospital or they
made a mistake who knows it seems based
on uh uh uh the evidence I've seen so
far my preliminary assessment is it is
more likely a Hamas rocket misfire than
Israel blung up a hospital yeah and and
that's what I believe um you know but
obviously there's information trying to
counter that narrative but that that is
just by what I saw what I've seen that's
what I believe it it seems to be the
simpler solution Hamas fired a rocket
these are makeshift improvised devices
they are powerful and it caused
tremendous damage to a
hospital it could have been a lot of
things but uh maybe the videos aren't
real we just don't know definitively but
I I I I feel like it's too cartoonishly
villainy to be like Israel blw up a
hospital full of children it's like okay
look like I understand there's a lot of
serious air strikes that are hitting
civilian areas but the narrative Isel
pushes out whether true or false doesn't
matter the statements they make as limit
civilian casualties the statements made
by Hamas videos of them parading around
the children they've captured and the
families they've killed exactly I'm
sorry dude exactly I I'm not giving
Hamas the benefit of the doubt on this
one no I can't do it plus what we've
seen it just leans in that direction but
I'm not I'm not claiming I know
definitively in Israel Israel is
completely innocent when it comes to
collateral damage or it's War what do
you what do you expect but this idea
that like you're going to trust Hamas
after there they put out a video of them
with the children of the families
they've kidnapped and they've been
publicly executing people yeah hostages
there's videos of them killing civilians
who are just driving their car like
pulling up to a kabut and they just walk
up to the car and just kill the drivers
yes I mean come on yeah at at the very
least Israel's like Hey we're trying to
Li limit civilian casualties and like
okay well I don't completely believe
you're doing an effective job at it
maybe AOC is right we need more
precision and intelligence in in the
issue but at the very least they're
saying it I don't know what else with a
rock remember the one Patriot missile
yeah going down the building remember
that mm- it was it in in the Iraq War
remember you don't remember this I was
I'm you're older than me I'm way older
than you uh yeah but so George Bush
launched this Iraq war and we kept
seeing I remember cuz my stepmother was
obsessed with watching it on CNN which
at the time was your basic news is what
it seemed like but they played you know
24-hour coverage and it was just you
kept seeing this one Patriot missile
like almost going down a chimney and
blowing stuff up it was really
fascinating so here's here's anoir Abu
Baker says Israel said they did it Tim I
have the tweet from Israel you are lying
no I didn't I mentioned during the show
that there was a guy who tweeted they
did it and then deleted the Tweet which
doesn't mean anything it it could be
that you just instantly believe he's the
bad guy because you're biased I don't
think a single tweet from someone saying
we did a thing and then deleting it
proves anything I think it's interesting
circumstantial evidence indicating
there's a possibility they did but I
don't know how we're going to know for
sure definitively we CU I have the tweet
from the Israeli official happy to share
it with you they did it I've also heard
from others that the the the official
who tweeted out isn't uh the individual
who tweeted out isn't actually an
official so uh what am I supposed to do
there huh yep there were reports that
Israel said they were going to have to
Target hospitals then there were reports
that Hamas said they were going to use
their biggest rocket right before this
right it's impossible to know anything
you cannot be emotionally attached to
any bit of news the second it comes out
no that's dangerous you have to be very
careful I'm going to pull up this uh
real quick I looked up the thing you
were talking about in Vice yeah it's
literally like do articles yeah the guy
the guy who tweeted this doesn't appear
the guy who tweeted this out that got
deleted is not an official with the
government he's a media personality it
just looked like it well and is that the
uh is that the one where the guy said he
was with Al jazer no okay cuz no that
one was annoying that's probably fake
that looked fake the account is deleted
and there's no one of that name working
at Al and check check when these Twitter
accounts were created please that one
was September right I saw I saw someone
retweet the person who spammed 500 posts
I work for Al jazer and was you know
what did they say it was Israel or heras
or whatever either way I ignore it cuz
I'm like get out of here with your Bot
garbage yep it looked very yeah anyway
that account is gone now smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you like it and head over to
timcast.net Facebook Twitter Instagram
and uh website morefor wv.com uh if you
want to check out my congressional race
sweet uh I'm Shane Cashman everywhere
online except for Tik Tok because they
banned me for my videos with Alex Jones
what the second they heard Alex's voice
they were nuked my account I don't care
I hate Tik Tok but uh Shane Cashman
everywhere you can find all my stories
at
timcast.net
I am dead naming for now for always and
you can check out everything we do at
the post millennial.age